[Musique]
à quoi ça sert l'amour on raconte
toujours des histoires insensées
à quoi ça sert d'aimer d'amour ne
s'explique pas c'est une chose comme ça
qui vient ou ne sait d'où et vous
pourquoi tout à coup
moi j'ai entendu dire que l'amour fait
souffrir l amour fait pleurer à quoi ça
sert d'aimer la moue ça sert à quoi à
vous donner de la joie
avec des larmes aux yeux c'est triste et
merveilleux
pourtant vie souvent l'amour c'est
décevant
pire il y en a un sur deux qui n'est
jamais heureux même quand on a perdu
l'amour qu'on a connu je vous laisse un
goût de miel l'amour cet éternel
tout ça c'est très joli mais quand tout
est fini
qu'il ne vous reste rien un immense
chagrin ou ceux qui maintenant te semble
déchirant demain sera pour toi un
souvenir de joie
en somme si j'ai compris ce en amoureux
dans la vie sans ses joies ses chagrins
on a vécu pour rien mais oui regarde moi
à chaque fois j'y crois et j'y croirai
toujours
ça sert à ça l'amour mais toi tu es le
dernier
mais toi tu es le premier
avant toi y avait rien avec toi je suis
bien chez toi que je voulais c'est tout
moi qu'il me fallait
toi que j'aimerai toujours ça sert à ça
là
[Musique]